chet hanks just dropped a new album too
yeah and he should drop it even further
dude that thing
no white boy summer was awesome until
you get to the second verse of that song
oh no i like the whole song and his new
his new one is a slapper
i wish him the best though now you hear
uh his dad cut him off because he smokes
weed in drinks
tom hanks [ __ ] force gump cut his son
off for smoking and drinking tom hanks
who couldn't even get out of the airport
for two months
or off an island for years yeah the guys
are obviously
stoner dude is he in greece no he well
he got
a citizenship in greece but he lives
here he lives in beverly hills yeah i
wore it i wore the white boy summer
shirt the other day i went to watch
rebirth brass band and warmer white boys
let me hear his new track doug
[Music]
[Music]
you don't really like it you're trying
to get them on your podcast no i like
you
you bought some you bought the shirt the
shirt i loved
sure before i heard the songs
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
her number
[Music]
yeah but katana is next to the comedy
store
it just never really hit a chorus that i
would that that's what i was looking for
oh you're looking for the catchy clown
oh my bad doctor drake
i was oh my bad dr drew
how many views on that huh 700 million
seven hundred sixty-two thousand
[Music]
sixty-two
[Music]
is